[Music]
all right Samuel Leeds here once again
and thank you for coming back to this
final video of the five point video
series we've gone through a lot of
information and I really hope to the
bottom of my heart that you have written
down taking good notes and you're
already implementing some of the stuff
that we've learned and one of the things
that I found happens a lot after people
have read the book and watch the video
series is they start booking viewings
building relationships with estate
agents they understand Lease Option
agreements they begin talking about it
thinking about it they begin to write
down a plan of action they get their
financial freedom figure that they're
going to set out and earn it in passive
income but they just need a little bit
of hand-holding and if you want if
you're like most people you'll probably
realize by now that the deals that you
find probably really that good unless
you've been in the game for a long time
we've been trained by an expert they're
probably okay but not that good
you'll probably realize by now that even
if they are good unless they're in your
area you're gonna need a Power Team
you're gonna need someone to HMO
managers HMO you're gonna need the best
solicitors you're gonna need the best
accountants and also the the changes
that are coming in you know you need to
be really brought up to speed so that is
why I have created and I've mentioned
before you might already be pre
registered it's for property investors
so people like yourself and it's called
the property investors crash course and
the reason it's called crash course is
because people literally arrive at this
program at the beginning on day one with
a little bit of knowledge you know some
idea literal experience or maybe even
absolutely not but they walk away at the
end of the two days as a professional
property investor and that is exactly
what you all do so I really wanted to
share
two points about this as well as
snipping him some golden nuggets of
advice and things that you need to do
power teams really important also
sourcing properties you know sometimes
you'll find a property here's a real big
mistake a lot of people do they'll find
a property and it might not fit with
their plan so you might find something
it might be a below market value deal
but you're looking for a HMO or it might
be HMO and you're affable and market
value deal it might be a cheap single
net properties it's going to give you a
25% return on investment but it just
doesn't work for you for whatever reason
so you have to turn that deal down well
what if I told you that every time that
happens you could pass that deal on for
a fee and make a couple thousand pounds
well I do that in the last 12 months
I've passed on I've traded over a
hundred properties now you can do the
math I've almost a quarter of a million
pounds just for going yeah that one
doesn't work for me and email account
and you know what that that seen nothing
stopping you do the exact same thing I
have dozens I have too many people
calling me wanting to do a lease option
agreement I can't even handle it I have
to get people from the crash course and
train them up and let them deal with it
and become partners with them it is
absolutely incredible because you know
what the property is a good thing to
invest in it is but property is number
two you know what the absolute best
thing to invest on is not silver it's
not gold the best thing to invest in is
you you're the best thing to invest in
you know you're more important than
property if you invest in yourself then
you'll know what planted property is to
invest in the best and that's why I put
together the property investors crash
course that this video right now it will
go out of date at some stage this videos
going to be out of date so at the crash
course we talked about all the new tax
changes the legislations the HMO around
new ways in order to maximize your
profits which if I did in a video they'd
probably be out of date so we go through
it every crash course we go through all
the new different things you talked
about how to raise finance I have people
literally begging me to invest their
money so imagine if you can find deals
and you had an unlimited amount of
untapped finance well guess what you
have you just don't have to give it and
that's what you learn at the crash
course so I don't mean to seem salesy or
pushy or anything like that it's just
I've seen how many lives the crash
course has changed and most importantly
you know when you come your walk away
with a game plan you'll walk away with a
game plan so I'd love you to join me for
a couple days and I've put a link below
in this video and there's a very special
offer right now I mean usually people
pay thousands of pounds to come to
programs like this it's two days the
first days 12 hour program
second is a little shorter it's compact
with knowledge and value and nuggets
yes it's high-energy because I'm that
kind of a person but it's content rich
and you will walk away much more
advanced much more professional
I'm much better educated than when you
came in so I've got a very special
offering right now it's in the link
below so what I would say is get
yourself booked on we always sell out we
always that we've never not sold out we
always sell out so get yourself booked
on right now if you want to see a little
bit of what happens then boom there's a
link right here click on the little
button a little eye button and you'll
get to see a little bit of what happens
a little bit of footage of the crash
course but get booked on I really look
forward to meeting you in person and
helping you in your journey to financial
freedom god bless
[Music]
you